what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time or while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with paulina the best it's
great
i don't know what she's wearing but it
looks awesome it almost looks like a
1970s sweater that you would find
where it's really fluffy uh don't forget
the lunch money is now sponsored by
block five block five has
three products one you can buy and sell
crypto on their crypto exchange two
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan to get your crypto
collateral
and three is that you can actually
deposit
crypto or stablecoin and earn up 8.6 apy
in their interest bearing account i'm an
investor i'm a user i'm a fan i'm
basically just
whatever whatever you want to call me i
like block five block five is great you
should go sign up for a black flight
account
you're a block fight stan sure i don't
know what that means that sounds like
something that young kids would say
or uh you guys will find out later this
week they also say
that's hard that which is the new code
for what would you say periscope
that's cool that's oh that's hot yeah
she used to say that's hot
i used to say like that's cool
that's sick you used to say that's
groovy i
wasn't born in the 70s your sweatshirts
from the 70s
uh so go check out blockfy.com pomp
again blockpike.com
all right let's go have we noticed
something different about our friend
over here
look at his hair it's be it's b it'd be
looking good
i had to go get a haircut i had a tree
growing out of the side of my head i
went there and i said listen
i need some forest management going on
up in here
and this is what we got hopefully we're
good hopefully
so grocery stores across the united
states are stocking up on
products to avoid shortages during a
second wave of coronavirus
household products including paper
towels and clorox wipes
have been difficult to find in during
the last
wave that's why southeastern grocers
bought its thanksgiving turkeys
and holiday hams over the summer months
before inventory planning normally
begins i feel like that's not
healthy well things like
toilet paper and clorox don't go bad so
i'm sure those are fine
but but there's a shortage no but
they're stocking up they're preparing
but right they're like preppers
basically the grocery stores are now
preppers but
they better be but the turkeys well the
food i think
can last for a long period of time
because they put all kinds of unhealthy
preservatives and things like that
in there uh so some people think you
should just go kill your own food just
kill what you eat
who thinks that well there's a
zuckerberg no
definitely not there's like a whole
community of of like uh meat eaters
and uh the cameron haynes of the world
uh the joe rogans of the world
that's what they do they literally go
hunting and they kill like
elk or whatever and then they basically
get it prepared so that they can just
eat that and it lasts like a whole
winter
that's stupid um but how do you think
the food gets there
so but um yes
no because i one time went fishing and
became friends with the fish
let's talk about this what is going on
here do you have buttons on this this is
ridiculous
all right wait you made friends with a
fish so i can't go fishing because i
made friends with the fish and then they
meet
i was a vegetarian for one night because
my grandparents were like okay now we're
gonna cook the fish and eat the fishness
like
that is bobby in there and i was petting
it i was playing with it and then they
put it on a plate
and i was like i don't eat my friends so
um but don't you remember that mark
zuckerberg
mark zuckerberg um like had one
challenge one new year's challenge where
like he only ate food that he like
killed himself all right just come on
let's just go
we got things to do i got places to be i
got 14 minutes and then i got things
that i got to be doing i got to get on
calls with people
who probably don't even want to talk to
me okay a facebook
co-founder is here mark zuckerberg is
only eating animals that he has killed
it's part of a personal challenge for
himself i told you he told patty sellers
that was back in 2000 exactly okay
doesn't mean
he didn't do it all right what's next a
judge
blocked the trump administration's ban
on new
tick-tock downloads from us app stores
the terms of the deal
to create a us-based tick tock global
still remain in flux
with by dance oracle and walmart why are
you laughing
because your your ears popping out it
kind of looks makes you look like an elf
all right judge blocks tick tock
downloads says that
or no it blocks the ban on the downloads
so tick tock's still in the app store
well get smaller ears so they don't pick
up all the sonic boom
going on all right uh look
this is gonna play out in court some
people think that it's legal some people
think it's illegal
who knows as i've continued to say if we
don't
want the chinese to do things
that they're doing kick them out you
know who
you know see ya you know who the real
you mean kick out tick tock
yeah uh you know who the real winner of
all of this is
who the ceo of tick tock who left and
said peace out i'm not dealing with this
[ __ ] yeah i don't know if he's a
winner but he definitely sidestepped a
lot of nonsense definitely
smart guy all right what's next nicola
the truck
stuff is coming out nicola founder
trevor milton reportedly purchased the
original design for the company's
flagship truck
from a croatia-based designer
nikola one the company's flagship
hydrogen-powered truck truck
truck truck is it the center of a design
please just crash okay is it the center
of a design patent infringement's
lawsuit that nikola filed against tesla
in 2018
nicola claims tesla semi its first
electric heavy duty truck
is substantially similar to nicola's
design
do you think musk is sitting in his
office right now like
no i think that tesla is the one who
went and found the fact that they bought
this
that's probably true yes uh well that's
this entire situation
does not look good remember what i told
you guys there's two red flags going on
here
they raised way too much money without
having a product
way too much every time this happens
quibby nicola
all of them when you see that happening
magic leap
magic leaf has a product but they raise
a lot of money beforehand and i don't
think it'll ever get commercialized
billion dollars okay go on just remember
when you see somebody raise a lot of
money without a product not a good sign
second no silicon valley investors
the best investors in the world this is
such a great idea why are they not
investors because they're already
investors in tesla
no most of them are not um the reason
why
is because they can smell the garbage
from a mile away
it's so obvious if you're gonna do weird
things
and you're going to be not a normal
ceo and build a company and and have
real value
then the professional investors are not
going to participate it's like we work
we work silicon valley didn't
participate
tonight nicola didn't participate i also
say something sure
this this uh backs up my theory that the
louder
somebody screams about something they're
likely doing it themselves they're just
trying to fend off the
the suspicion so like if they're going
around
claiming patent infringement and now
they've actually done something well
they didn't do anything wrong in terms
of i read the story basically because i
read the internet
uh basically what happened is he went to
a designer
like a like a truck designer that lives
in croatia
uh spent some time with him bought the
designs for an electric truck
and then brought him back to the united
states now he
he claims that he came up with the
designs in his
basement like and he worked on it when
this came out
supposedly now they're saying yes we
bought these designs
but the nikola one design is different
than this like road runner design or
whatever
who knows what actually happened i
haven't seen the designs a court will
figure it all out was there fraud was or
not whatever all we know is that the
founder is out
he still somehow got three billion
dollars of stock though
uh billion yeah or 2.5 billion or like
some ridiculous amount of money
but the point being if they raise too
much money
and you don't see the best investors in
the world in a deal that's getting tons
of hype
be very cautious suspicious yes
suspicious be suspicious sally
all right why are you out of the frame
always get get back in
okay okay not like that all right come
on let's go all seven
members of boy band bts it's a k-pop
band have become multi-millionaires
after their label
big hit entertainment pulled off south
korea's
biggest stock market listing in three
years they're millionaires their
producer is a billionaire
yeah but i don't understand why that's a
big deal the company got valued at four
billion dollars
of course they're multi-millionaires
yeah but it's kind of cool that like
these
boy band members but but hold on
there's a bunch of information being uh
shared here in this article that maybe
is a little uh misleading not telling
the whole story
first of all can you not it's not the
band that went public
i know it's the label it's the label and
that label
has multiple streams of revenue from the
band they probably actually have other
ones as well
other bands in there uh but this guy oh
there's gonna be a whole name
ceo bang c hua
hoop hoop is a long time music producer
who is credited with creating them and
setting it on the road to stardom in
2013.
he owns 43 of big hit entertainment
which is the company
according to stock exchange filings the
ipo made him
a billionaire uh and then he gave each
of the bts band members
uh 68 000 shares in august those
holdings are now worth
nearly eight million dollars each at the
issuing price
now he gave it to them but why is this
misleading when you're reading from the
article
because everyone is talking about the
fact that these
uh the band members like took the same
public it's a whole company it's got a
ceo behind
it and he became a billionaire and they
didn't
okay they got eight million dollars he
got a billion okay but eight million for
a boy band member come on
that's nothing they're they're one of
the most popular groups in the world
their company is worth 4 billion they
got 8 million
the group is one of the few k-pop bands
to break into western markets
last year bts became only the third
group in 50 years after the beatles and
the monkeys
monkeys or monkeys to have three number
one
albums you don't even know to have three
numbers
go ahead go ahead doesn't know you know
he's virtue signaling
three number one albums on the billboard
200 charts in less than 12 months
wow just so we all are on the same page
eight million dollars of a four billion
dollars
means that they have point two percent
ownership
that's what he gave them how many people
are in this band a lot of the a lot of
the artists don't
even get anything when their label or
whatever goes public
the fact that they have 69 000 shares
what okay is that not true no totally
is it not true you're right i don't know
exactly that's what i wanted
i do know they made a four billion
dollar company and they only got eight
million dollars
all right next the artist never gets
paid they are lucky come on
elon musk criticizes openai exclusively
licensing
gpt 3 to microsoft wait doesn't he own
open api or
he used to be a board member but he
resigned i think because he said that
there was a conflict so
it was co-founded by him it's a
non-profit research company that
he co-founded along with sam altman a
bunch of other people so in a tweet
following the news that the company
acquired an exclusive license for gpt-3
a language model created by openai that
generates human-like text elon said
this does seem like the opposite of open
open ai is essentially captured
by microsoft he's got a point
if you name yourself open ai and the
whole idea is to be open source but then
you give an exclusive license
to microsoft why not they're giving them
out
no it's exclusive nobody else can get
one so it's not very open it sounds
pretty closed to me
okay elon but yeah i mean i mean look
he's just a seeker of truth people may
not like it but
that's what happens all right next we
have five minutes what do you like
five minutes nasa okay hold on
so nasa has released its first ever
agency-wide economic report documenting
the agency's impact on the nation's jobs
and cash flow
everyone knew nasa was impactful but now
we know exactly how impactful
some
some success billion dollars and more
than 300 000 jobs worth
in fiscal year 2019. that's a lot
well i don't know why it took a 2 670
page report to figure that out
but 2 seventy page report
okay but the point is three hundred
thousand jobs and sixty four billion
how many of the three hundred thousand
people did it take to write the two
thousand six hundred seventy page report
never writing anything the other day i
showed him how i organized my
work and he was like i was like i can do
this for you
and he was like no that that's too
organized for me
yeah i i can't i can't operate in that
world
honestly instead of a joke i have a joke
but we should just tell the ice cream
story
all right go to the next topic and then
i'll tell you that's that's the final
topic that's it
and wait let me give you my joke real
quick because it's good
the police showed up when my son refused
to take a nap
they charged him with resisting arrest
these are so bad these are so good
arrests
he wasn't rested all right ready okay so
last night
we decided we were going to go for a
walk and then we saw a cvs and polina
had to get something
uh from cvs some photos that she had
ordered uh which i didn't even know they
were real photos
like just use them on the computer but
whatever hold on uh so we go in the cbs
and you know she's like
talking to the photo person oh my god
this is not interesting to me i wonder
what else they have here in cbs
this is a nice cvs this is yeah this was
a very nice cbs
they had perfume people out there and so
i i started looking around i was like
there's a refrigerator area i bet you
they got some ice cream i think i need
some ice cream so hold on the photo area
where i dropped him off
he had to walk all the way around the
city
just dropped me off i just i walked away
from my parental
uh guardian and i was exploring the
story what did you do
and so when i got there i was like oh
they got ice cream uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna grab me a drumstick you know
with the cone and you could like walk
around and eat it
and i was hype and then i would open the
thing and it wouldn't open i was like
what the hell
it was like maybe it's just stuck so i
tried another door it went open now i
realized
that they had a lock on the ice cream
doors
and i was like this is a predicament i
want this like
jacob i want this ice cream but they
won't let me get it they're trying to
keep me from being fat
i was like no i'm gonna get fat today
you ain't gonna stop me i'm gonna get
fat today so by the way so while i'm
pulling on the thing it won't open so
i'd say okay let me figure this out so
while all this is going on
i i've now wandered around a little bit
waiting for him and i'm at the cash
register just waiting because
it's been a while he just it's like 10
o'clock at night too so they're like
what's going on here so i see a button
like a customer service like call help
button
so i can't resist i call it and i just
think it's gonna like
beep somebody and they're gonna come
next thing i know
over the loudspeaker of the store uh you
know
customer needs help in aisle nine and
i'm like oh [ __ ]
like oh man guy walks up got the key
ready he knows
aisle nine there must be a fat dude
waiting to get some ice cream
walks up with the key uh and so i'm like
i'd like to get a drumstick please
and he's like no problem like like he
does this all day so i'm like alright
this is weird so as he's unlocking it i
say hey man
i gotta ask why is the ice cream locked
up he goes oh
they come in here and i said who's they
and he goes to homeless people the drug
addicts
because they come in here with big bags
and they basically open it
and then they just scoop all of it into
their bags and then just
walk out right so they just like steal
ice cream the ice cream is very close to
the door
yeah so well i didn't understand all
this so then he like hands me my drum
well i grabbed my drumsticks i'm very
particular about which one
you can't get the ones that are too you
know frozen but also not too soft
getting the right one
uh it's kind of like what is it uh
goldilocks you know like just right
um and so i grab my ice cream and i
start to walk away and then i pause
and i can't resist and i turn around and
i look at him
and then i look next to me into the new
in the refrigerator i'm next to now
where all the alcohol is and i say hey
man
y'all got the ice cream locked up but
you don't have the beer locked up
and he goes yeah we don't have enough
locks
meanwhile i am still waiting at the cat
to the checkout counter i'm like i don't
know where he went so i show up what's
up
swag walking i walk over with my ice
cream and
uh i hit her she's like where were you
and i was like they got the ice cream
lock they're trying to keep me from
being fat but i'm not gonna be stopped
by some stupid lock
and the guy behind the cash register
lost it absolutely lost i think we're
banned from the cvs
i asked him he should he should pay me
money for that uh
comedy show that he got to witness it's
okay though that's it for lunch monday
today go get your ice cream get rid of
the locks at cvs we'll talk to you guys
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends